[Musique]
toi papa qui veut qui veut qu'on regarde
pas la télé eh ben on est non on s'est
mieux on est dedans et ben débouler un
papa est d'abord qu'on est dedans et toi
tu vas jamais l'arroseur des d'accord
papa 14 ans et c'est pour dire à tous
ceux qu'on ménage
il ya des filles qui nous plaisent peut
même le plus particulièrement une note
en ce moment est bon ben c'est pas trop
polluée alors il faut y aller il faut
avoir le courage
moi je parle enfin je parle au nom d'une
fille qui s'appelle je n'aime pas
[Musique]
bonjour j'espère que tu t'es reconnu
j'espère que tu vas me remettrai 100
francs est-ce qu'il ne faut absolument
tout de suite tu veux pas me rendre
droite sacré problème je vois que tu
t'es reconnu ses deux marques de
marocains ça sang-froid études en iran
tout de suite un hockey et olé rappeur
s'il ya un petit rappeur je voudrais
passer le bonjour à ma famille à mon
papillon phase de la façon café de la
plage mais des phrases comme ça c'est
que plus il n'est pas tombé dès que l'on
capte des côtés je veux savoir qui
n'oublie pas que c'est bientôt
l'anniversaire était trop complexe
bonjour je m'appelle olivier bonnet je
voudrais vous faire savoir
je cherche une petite amie bon je sais
c'est pas une très belle gueule mais bon
ça peut aller
salut c'est nul et ont peur du siècle
comme ils en ont arrêté non maintenant
applaudi samedi c'est pas ça se fera moi
on me demandait un gars étaient convenus
je suis à bouchehr je trouve pas condédé
playboy 30 pas qu'il ya 5 millions de
français qui me regardent la non six ans
sans meyong ouais nan mais sérieux on
est des bruits de plaies à vendre g par
année mais lui est franchement dans le
rouge la gfa nourriture en tirer
ça fait neuf mois que j'ai avec ma
copine safadi mois s'appelle ingrid je
suis soutenu voilà on est trois que
battre le premier à me voilà on a un
problème c'est qu'il ya une fille enfin
il y avait des filles et maintenant il
ya une fille en valeur et maintenant ça
fait dj est allée des problèmes et comme
dit encouragé il ya en face parce que
j'ai pas de raison qu ici c'est fini à
j'ai pris du bon travail m
mais bon
je lance un peu parce que eux ils
veulent pas comprendre qu' on peut être
amoureux des filles comme moi on est
amoureux faut pas laisser tomber les
copains parce que c'est vraiment la
meilleure si ça va leur faire part des
missions se prendre soin de ma
conscience moi même franchement
christophe est un truc c'est qu'il faut
pas qu'il nous abandonne pas ce contador
c'est tout voilà c'est tout et on on
l'avait tellement de choses ensemble
je ne sais pas possible que ça s'arrête
comme ça à cause d'une meuf mais si tu
l'as d'or voilà on ne la retire quelque
chose de très important on sert à passer
un message à tous les jeunes qui nous
regarde pas sortez couverts ouais c'est
vrai emportements voila voila bonjour je
m'appelle charlie j'ai 23 ans je
recherche d'une femelle pour mon
yorkshire
alors si vous avez une femelle du type
yorkshire qui est aussi aussi mignon que
aussi mignonne que le mien eh bien vous
me n'hésitez pas à téléphoner mois chez
moi au 39 84 04 54 pas je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui pourquoi je me suis habillée
en garçon parce que j'ai plus envie de
m'habiller en femme
non j'ai subi les caprices d'un chef et
oui l'heure seulement sexuelle ça existe
les deux messages
1 pour les mecs ans pour mon mec premier
message
les mecs vous en supplie arrêtez de vous
toucher les coucougnettes ou alors ce
qu'il vous le faites faites le
discrètement la oui ça existe et tous
les jours même dans le métro
moi j'en ai ras-le-bol jeu mais je vous
le dis
suis contente de parler aujourd'hui et
il faut vraiment c'est que cette
mentalité change ne peut pas continuer
comme ça deuxième message c'est pour
jérôme chéreau je t'aime oui je t'aime
mais s'il te plaît le foie les menottes
tu les rangées au placard ok merci
by pr lâcher un coup de gueule contre
nos surveillants parce que ouais ils
s'arrêtent pas de lâcher des heures de
colle un peu et puis tu vois on est dans
les toilettes seuil et en parle un peu
sortez vous sera coulé pendant trois
heures
je comprends pas tellement pourquoi les
gens bons à paris particulièrement parce
que je sais pas comment ça se passe en
province
il regarde un petit peu de travers quand
je suis avec une copine
bon c'est vrai que la copine à elle a
quelques années de plus que moi quelques
décennies pas beaucoup deux décennies je
vous rassure tout de suite ça fait six
mois je sais à paris et je voudrais dire
que les parisiens connaissent un peu
comme des cons mais comptent un type de
bon ménage moi je fais plus jeune je
fais 22 ans
paris que j'ai 27 ans ça fait six
matches à paris je suis monté pour
essayer de trouver quelque chose de
viable et moi et tout s est très dur
c'est marrant très très dur je
déconseille de monter à paris
c'était une ville de merde tout est très
cher et je vous demande simplement un
truc faut pas comment dire ah je vous
aime faut pas vous étonner si je suis
avec une femme plus âgée il faut vous
dire ce type là bon il aime les femmes
plus âgées et basse et c'est bien pour
lui quoi
salut je vois ça va changer deux ans et
pays bas dont trois fois je vais
peut-être plus sur moi puisque j'étais
de région alors c'est si vous avez un
truc quoi contenter france 3 puis vous
me contacter bonjour papa
on a déjà parlé mais je ne pense pas ce
que je pourrais avoir une paire de
voyeur stopper tout et achèterait enfin
je veux vous dire que j'adore michael
jackson est déjà michael jackson et que
je torse comme michael jackson la preuve
grâce à tes les bobines vous avez la
chance de voir la nôtre aujourd'hui 26
mai c'est l'anniversaire de delphine
j'ai pensé à elle toute la journée et je
lui souhaite un très heureux
anniversaire
delphine je tiens aussi avec un peu de
retard bien sûr adresser mes meilleurs
voeux d'anniversaire en thaïlande
c'est sylvie prière annoncé suffisamment
à l avance
vos dates de fiançailles
car votre date de fiançailles car mon
emploi du temps est extrêmement chargé
merci au revoir à bientôt
[Musique]